الكثير من الدموع على ضحية أخرى من ضحايا
الحرب الروسية في أوكرانيا.
يحترق
منزلنا وقد دمر هناك متجر
بالقرب من مبنى الآن لم يعد موجودًا
في هذه المدينة المحاصرة في جميع أنحاء البلاد
ولا يزال الملايين يعيشون بدون كهرباء
تتهم أوكرانيا روسيا
بالاستهداف المستمر لمنشآت الطاقة الأوكرانية
مما يمنح المهندسين القليل من الوقت
لإصلاح الشبكات من قبل  الإضراب التالي يأتي
وزير الطاقة الأوكراني يصف
الوضع في جميع أنحاء بلاده بأن
الضربات الصعبة حقًا تركت أوكرانيا
تعاني من عجز في الطاقة غير قادر على تلبية
احتياجات الطاقة الأساسية للبلاد.المخاوف تتزايد
بين المسؤولين الأوكرانيين.
في هذه القرية الصغيرة بالقرب من ابنها
الناس ب  نتسابق من أجل شتاء قارس البرودة
شتاء بدون كهرباء لجمع
الحطب والإمدادات الأخرى للحماية من
درجات الحرارة المنخفضة ،
سنمر خلال الشتاء
لأننا نصلح المدخنة
والآن يمكننا تدفئة المنزل سنتجاوزه
ليس لدينا أي خيار آخر  إلى أين
سنذهب فوق كل هذا حرب كلامية
تختمر بين موسكو وكييف
وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف يصدر
إنذارًا يجب على أوكرانيا أن تذعن
لمطالب روسيا بما في ذلك التخلي عن
الأراضي الأوكرانية المحتلة وإلا
فإن الجيش الروسي سيتولى زمام
الأمور بنفسه
يقول الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي إنه لن يحدث ، فهو يتعهد
باستعادة جميع الأراضي الأوكرانية التي تم الاستيلاء عليها.